Помітили різницю?
Праворуч - звичний спосіб робити покупки
запаковуючи все в одноразові пластикові пакети
Ліворуч - приклади того, як можна уникнути пластикових відходів
Адже найчастіше вони не піддаються переробці
і дуже довго розкладаються
Чотири роки тому в Бонні відкрився магазин Freikost Deinet
Покласти товар тут можна в принесену з собою багаторазову тару або взяти її в магазині напрокат
Вага упаковки на касі віднімається.
Платиш тільки за вміст
Звісно, до походу в такий магазин
треба як слід підготуватися
Майже як в старі добрі часи
паперові і полотняні торби, скляні банки
харчові контейнери і навіть сітка для прання
В нагоді стануть будь-які види тари
Перший раз незвично,
але для постійних покупців - рутина
Багато з них їдуть в цей магазин з віддалених районів - і навіть з інших міст
Мені подобається ідея
відмовитися від одноразової упаковки
Я хочу, щоб удома було менше сміття
Ми вже багато років купуємо екологічно чисті продукти
якщо можливо, без упаковки
Якщо по-іншому ніяк,
використовуємо паперові пакети
Мені подобається, що тут можна
приносити з собою посуд і банки
їх можна зважити
Коли я йду за покупками в інші магазини
доводиться говорити:
не кладіть товар у пластиковий пакет
Іноді це працює, іноді ні
Ідею відкрити такий магазин Гільке Дайнет
привезла з подорожі Австралією
Коло клієнтів міні-маркету в Бонні
постійно розширюється
Ми бачимо, що даємо поштовх
до зміни свідомості покупців
Слід зазначити, що вони охоче
приймають такі правила гри
Адже проблема в тому, що багато хто й сам хотів би
робити покупки інакше
але часто, коли приходиш у звичайний магазин
зі своєю тарою
на тебе косо дивляться, і ти почуваєшся ніяково
Звичайні супермаркети теж докладають зусиль
щоб зменшити обсяги пластикового сміття
Тепер у багатьох з них на касі продають
не пластикові
а паперові або полотняні торби
Використання пластикових пакетів у Німеччині
за 15 років скоротилося майже вдвічі
Особливо після того, як два роки тому багато магазинів одягу, техніки та інших товарів
припинили видавати
безкоштовні пластикові пакети
Власники магазину Freikost Deinet закуповують тільки екологічно чисті продукти
переважно у регіональних постачальників
Звісно, такі продукти коштують дорожче
Це відповідно зменшує рентабельність
Ми не хочемо вести бізнес так
як це часто роблять інші супермаркети
Коли, наприклад, викинути
овочі або фрукти дешевше
ніж найняти персонал, який сортує
придатні для вживання продукти
Я не можу прийняти такий підхід
ні серцем, ні головою
Десяток яєць, огірок, кілька яблук, півкіло рису
200 грамів сиру і шматок мила
все це обійшлося нам в 20 євро
У звичайному німецькому супермаркеті
було б удвічі дешевше
Утім, звідси йдеш не тільки з якісними,
екологічно чистими продуктами
а й з чистою совістю